bonjour à tous chiant laurent chers amis
je très heureux de vous retrouver dans
pas très frais parce que j'étais encore
à 6h15 dans l'hémicycle parce que
figurez vous que c'est comme ça qu'on
nous fait travailler à l'assemblée
nationale ils sont pas fichus de gérer
l'agenda de l'assemblée nationale et on
est obligé de siéger y compris de nuit
pour voter un texte très important sur
les entreprises
comment voulez vous qu'un parti
politique en marge qui est pas capable
de gérer l'argent d'elle d'assaut
nationale soit capable de gérer la
france c'est le bazar partout et on en a
marre voilà et on espère très bien
revenir aux commandes pour mieux gérer
notre pays et notre agenda à l'assemblée
alors moi je suis fier de vous présenter
le budget 2010 8 exécuter le projet de
budget 2010 9
parce qu'à travers ces chiffres bien
évidemment c'est aussi une certaine
façon de gérer notre pays
dès demain que nous voulons vous montrer
comme l'a très bien dit jean bien géré
notre parti et c'est aussi le slogan de
laurent et je sais qu'ils s'attachent
aussi à bien gérer cette région la
région auvergne rhône-alpes est l'une
des meilleures régions
du point de vue de sa gestion de france
avec avec la normandie avec un homme
ordinaire hervé mardi aussi c'est bien
mais c'est en démontrant à la tête de la
région laurent et elle était du parti sa
capacité à bien gérer ta région et le
parti que demain voilà tu seras à la
fois bien gérer notre pays
bravo à toi et merci pour ta confiance
alors quelques chiffres très rapidement
et ce document vous sera communiquée à
chacun d'entre vous bien évidemment
l'exercice 2010 vie tout d'abord c'est
un exercice à léquilibre puisque alors
je ne sais pas si vous avez
communication des tableaux sinon je vais
vous faire ça à l'oral voilà donc
l'exercice projeté à l'équilibré en 2018
nous avions eu des recettes en repli
mais face à des recettes en repli qu'est
ce que l'on a fait mettre simplement on
a fait des économies de fonctionnement
parce que aux républicains on dépense
pas l'argent qu'on n'a pas à la
différence de ce que fait monsieur macro
qui dépensent chaque jour l'argent des
français qu'il n'a pas et dans ce
contexte budgétaire donc nous avons pu
retrouver un équilibre dans notre budget
est reversé 3,4 millions d'euros aux
fédérations en 2018
nous avons également poursuivi le
désendettement quai 21
entamée dès 2015 et nous la fin 2018 la
dette qui était de 74 5 millions d'euros
fin 2014 a été ramené à 49,5 millions
d'euros donc s'agissant de l'exercice
2010 8
nous avons tenu notre feuille de route
maîtriser nos dépenses est adapté nos
dépenses par rapport au niveau de
recettes et nous avons poursuivre d
entêtement du parti et bien évidemment
nous avons financé la vie du parti
notamment celle des fédérations la
feuille de route pour 2019 et la même
alors très rapidement
je vais vous présenter les grandes
lignes du budget 2010 9 pour lequel vous
aurez à voter dans quelques instants
en 2019 nous allons poursuivre la
maîtrise des dépenses de fonctionnement
ce que ne fait pas monsieur macron qui
descend déraper les dépenses de l'état
nous avons anticipé des recettes
prudente bien évidemment nous avons un
budget d'action politique qui est
rehaussée puisque nous avons notamment à
financer les élections européennes
et puis nous avons poursuivi le
désentettement du parti et ça fait
partie des bonnes nouvelles que je peux
vous annoncer ce matin donc au total
nous vous présentons un budget pour 2010
9 qui est exempt excédentaire de 700000
euros alors s'agissant des dépenses de
fonctionnement elles seront toujours
maîtrisé et notamment les dépenses de
personnel a aussi ce que ne sait pas
faire monsieur macron qu'ils avaient
promis une diminution du nombre de
fonctionnaires alors qu'il cesse
d'embaucher de nouveaux fonctionnaires
le désendettement du parti nous permet
de faire des économies substantielles
et quant aux dépenses courantes de
fonctionnement
eh bien elles vont continuer à être
maîtrisé comme en 2000
18 en ce qui concerne les recettes nous
avons des estimations de recettes qui
sont prudentes les cotisations des lieux
avec un objectif de 2,6 millions d'euros
il ya beaucoup de présidents de
fédérations secrétaires départementaux
de trésorier d'amis qui sont venus d'un
peu partout en france je le dis et
j'insiste sur ce point on peut pas
demander aux militants de payer leurs
cotisations
parfois sur leurs dépenses sur leur
cagnotte personnelle de payer des frais
d'essence et de passer du temps au
profit du parti et quand on est élu
grâce à ses militants ne pas payer ses
cotisations d'élus voilà cette
inacceptable
l'enjeu demande
je demande au président de fédération
skatar département des eaux trésorier la
plus grande fermeté à ce sujet en ce qui
concerne les dons nous avons un objectif
qui est prudent en ce qui concerne les
adhésions également et nous allons
continuer à reverser aux fédérations ce
que nous devons leur verser je rappelle
cette règle il faut que vous l'ayez en
tête à chaque fois que vous faites une
adhésion les deux tiers reviennent à la
fédération
c'est la règle des deux tiers un tiers
c'est un tiers pour le national et deux
tiers pour vous à chaque fois qu'il ya
un élu qui paye sa cotisation d'élus
c'est les deux tiers pour votre
fédération de protéger à cette règle
c'est très important parce que si vous
voulez plus de moyens pour aux
fédérations et bien fait plus
d'adhésions fait plus de dons faites
plus de cotisations d'élus et toi et le
ciel t'aidera donc plutôt que de vous
tendez votre trésorier national
multiplier les dons les adhésions et les
cotisations des lui vous verrez que vous
votre cagnotte départementale va se
remplir toutes seules un financement
l'action politique en hausse de 50% et
notamment nous serons en capacité cette
année de dd notre candidat françois
xavier bellamy que je salue agnès arnaud
et et toute cette formidable liste que
nous sommes très heureux voilà d'épaulé
et ils le feront à notre place
évidemment en tant que trésorier seul
avec l'équipe qui est la mienne puisque
nous pourrons faire un don de 2 millions
d'euros à notre candidat une pour nous
porter caution pour la même somme ce qui
permettra donc de financer la campagne
des européennes
nous pouvons financer la campagne des
européennes sans faire appel à personne
d'autre c'est grâce à notre bonne
gestion et j'en suis vraiment très fier
un dernier point et je tient évidemment
tous ces chiffes à votre disposition
vous le savez rigueur et transparence
nous sommes le parti politiqué le plus
transparent dans ce dossier tel qui vous
est présentée sera distribuée
immédiatement après cette présentation à
la presse voilà et tous journalistes ou
militants tout français qui va avoir
accès au camp des républicains
il y aura accès nous n'avons rien à
cacher nous sommes une maison de verre
c'est très très important est là aussi
cette transparence et rigueur nous
l'appliquerons demain aux finances du
pays alors qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui les
informations qu'on voudrait avoir de la
part de monsieur maquereau ou la part de
bercy
et puis le dernier point concerne la
dette
et ça c'est un point très important
alors que monsieur macron ne cesse
d'endetter notre pays nous nous avons
désendetter notre mouvement et je veux
vraiment remercier laurent parce qu'il
m'a vraiment voilà épaules et je crois
qu'on a fait vraiment un très très bon
travail avec laurent avec nos équipes
puisque nous avons vendu le siège que
nous louons et grâce à cette opération
eh bien je suis fier de vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui les républicains ont
baissé leurs dettes de 80 %
si monsieur nacre on pouvait en faire
autant pour le pays la france irait
beaucoup mieux et la dette résiduelle
on avait une tête de 75 millions d'euros
qui étaient ramenés à 13 millions ses 13
millions ne seront pas remboursés
qu'après les élections de 2022 ce qui
veut dire que toutes les marges de
manoeuvre que nous allons nous dégager à
partir de maintenant nous pouvons les
garder pour nous mêmes pour financer la
campagne des européennes mais aussi la
campagne des régionales départementales
et bien évidemment nous allons dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et sur
ses bases financières saines pouvoir
préparer la campagne de 2022 pour
revenir à l'elysée
et pour reprendre la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et pour redresser
notre pays
en conclusion je voudrais remercier
vraiment laurent wauquiez de tout coeur
nos vices présidences dans les ti
guillaume pottier et damien abad
notre secrétaire général a dit jon var
merci à toi l'ensemble du bureau
politique
tout ce qui chacun à leur place parce
que si chacun d'entre vous que je veux
remercier empire votre cotisation en
agissant pour le parti va c'est vous qui
le fait vivre
rien ne serait possible sans vous donc à
grand merci à vous tous je crois que
vous pouvez vous applaudir parce que
vous êtes formidables bravo et merci
le redressement financier du parti ne
serait pas possible sans vous et merci à
dernier à bercy a également les membres
du côté du comité financier avec un
remerciement particulier je termine sur
ce point pour françois noël buffet qui
accepte et voilà avait à mes côtés bien
de cette assurer non seulement ces
revenants ce comité financier mais
également d'assurer le financement de la
campagne des européennes donc merci a
toi françois noël
merci à toi de m'accompagner depuis ses
années dans son redressement financier
du parti
merci à vous êtes formidables et comme
vous êtes formidables vous allez voter
donc vous devriez avoir des cartons
tout à l'heure je disais que quand on
met un carton rouge on sort en football
et en rugby mais enfin là on va les
tolérer mais si elle a pas beaucoup
c'est mieux donc je vous propose
d'adopter le budget qui vous a été
présentée par notre trésorier
montrez-moi bien les bulletins là je
considère que c'est un vote unanime qui
valide qui valide
l'action que tu as mené et on applaudit
une fois de plus daniel fasquelle bon
non il ya une absorption et hervé morin
qui obtient parce qu'il n'est pas du
parti mais il va contribuer
financièrement largement la campagne
européenne et donc on le remercie aussi
voilà chers amis merci daniel je vais
appeler annie genevard que vous
connaissez que notre secrétaire